hallo mein name ist luganesi willkommen
zu einer weiteren folge sims 4 sind beim
letzten mal hier stehen geblieben dass
luca wir wohnen ja immer noch hier in
diesem schnitten geilen haus weil wir ja
neuerdings millionäre sind meine damen
und herren da wir ja zehn millionen auf
dem konto habe ich mir gedacht wir
machen diese folge immer irgendwie so
story mäßig was was nur millionäre
machen man ich komme überhaupt nicht
klar mit diesem scheiß stockwerken hier
egal wo ich irgendwo hingehe das geht
immer hoch und runter die kamera oder
mich wir dann geht es wieder runter und
hier dann will ich auf luca dotti wieder
hoch genug als millionär sein auf jeden
fall schlafen
das müssen wir ihm das wir warten erst
mal ein paar stunden 2000 jahre später
ohne spaß
ich hab jetzt wirklich ultra lang
gewartet wir sind hier unten schon bei 9
uhr 30 gleich und lukas immer noch nicht
fertig mit penn mittlerweile ist luca
endlich mal aufgewacht es fühlt sich
sehr unwohl was eine stadt muss dringend
pausen liebesbrief max ist natürlich
schon wieder schön am zocken hier und
luca wo ist der eigentlich natürlich
sitzt luka und auf toilette die erste
sache die rich kids machen draußen schön
mit der familie im anzug luca erstickt
innerhalb am essen schöner brunch mit
der familie
hier das ist ja und alle haben keinen
bock auf das essen halt verbraten
flugzeugkauf alt bin mutter und dann kam
aber der redner konnten wir nicht
fliegen weil das kann ich natürlich
nicht und dann bin ich aber tatsächlich
irgendwann hamam ist das illegal mich
mit meinem flugzeugs und sonne geflogen
aber zuschauen wie da der ausblick so
ist hab da mal geburtstag gefeiert
nach einem entspannten frühstücks brunch
steht luca jetzt erst mal runter angeln
weil das ist das was multi millionäre
auf jeden fall auch machen mal schauen
ob er den einen oder anderen fisch an
land zieht eine ewigkeit später sollte
das ist ja nicht wahr
der kriegt echt nichts hindert eine
junge dame vida du bist multimillionär
wieso okay du hast du schon alleine
kommt lukan kommt das gesehen das glaubt
was machen den millionäre noch sowas
reiche leute natürlich auch so machen
ist richtig viele partys schmeißen da
ich nicht so genau weiß wie das ganze
funktioniert habe ich mir jetzt einfach
mal sehr viele freunde aus meiner alten
nachbarschaft geschnappt unter anderem
johnny schwarz vielleicht kennen einige
von euch noch ein schwarzes ist dieser
komische fritze hier ohne freunde
nun begeben sich alle schön in das
kommen wir da nicht rein was soll das
denn jetzt sein alter ich wollte schon
mit meinen teams kollegen hier in das
haus rein und dachte ich kann irgend
eine tolle party schmeißen aber wir
können grillen naja aus dem wir grillen
ist jetzt irgendwie mehr oder weniger
san luca grillt alleine geworden
du kannst steht hier hinten und geht
alleine meine ganzen freunde stehen da
vorne kann ich nicht eben schnell die
bude kaufen und eine richtig fette party
drin schmeißen oder sondern ihm an ich
will doch nur gucken was multimillionäre
immer so
von luca ich finds echt schön wo ist
luca das kann doch nicht sein
dieser junge ist luca was tust du denn
da erzeugt genug
ich wohne hier auch und auszulegen so
auch du auch hast du auch regen ich
nehme meistens let's play off in meiner
freizeit abbauen youtube kanal und lese
sehr viele bücher weil was für diese mit
dem blöden regen lasst uns trocken sex
haben
was will sie denn hier direkt die
seniorin das was multi millionäre
natürlich auch zu machen ist einfach mit
freunden beisammen sein ich die schöne
natur hier anschauen und eigentlich sind
das alles überhaupt nicht sachen die
millionäre machen aber ich dachte ich
guck mal was gibt tipps fürs ich kann
diese spielen die anderen machen diese
karriere ich titel i 10 millionen zu
million stehe mit zehn kollegen von mir
an bank- und johnny schwarz sein herz
ist gebrochen ich würde unglaublich gern
mal in sims mit party schmeißen oder am
pool bau nächste folge baulichen pool an
der stelle würde ich jetzt aber trotzdem
sagen meine damen und herren
wenn euch das video gefallen hat würde
wogegen die alle hin ich würde mich über
eine bewertung freuen weil sims geil ist
und ich las gern öfter hoch und schreib
mir gerne kommentare nicht kommentare
sondern wer tipps zu ein schwieriges
wort in die kommentare damit und dann
sehen wir uns in einem nächsten video
wie der chio